harry's is just too good man yes the
aries was
that broken after the launch of episode
4 the exciting release of neon some map
and gun changes
all anyone could talk about
was this
what is this gun
wait this this has to be hot fixed a
week later the aries was nerfed thank
god and for me
it begs one very important question is
it even possible to get any of these
secondary or tertiary weapons right
should riot games just leave us with our
phantom our vandal and our pistols and
let us go on our merry way forever
let's discuss
[Music]
look i'm hooked on balance i'm addicted
to ranked
i'm addicted to losing and i'm addicted
to buying skins so if you want us to
keep this valerian content coming make
sure you scroll down hit the subscribe
button like the video and leave us a
comment okay so if you've been playing
valorent this act
i don't need to tell you just how
overpowered the aries was a week ago as
far as the competitive community is
concerned the buffs to this lmg
completely overshadowed the release of
neon it instantly became the go-to
half-by weapon and could cut down even
fully armed enemies with ease thankfully
riot games acted fast on january 19th
just eight days after the changes they
released patch 4.01 which included well
almost exclusively sweeping changes to
the aries they made it more expensive
made the recoil more intense made the
bullet spread much wider and perhaps
most importantly
they made it much worse when crouching
and for the most part i'd say that
more or less it worked the gun has
become an option for half buys mostly on
defense but it's no longer the menace it
was a week ago
despite the fact that is extremely loud
still and very annoying to play against
and that my friends is where my thesis
for today's video begins the fact that
even after the nerfs even when the aries
is just an option
it still tilts the [ __ ] out of all of us
in ranked and it's part of a larger
trend of riot trying to make these
non-pistol non-rifle guns work
only to end up with sometimes broken
weapons and a play experience that's
just
not what anyone signed up for and trust
me i know what i'm saying is true
because every other time it's happened
i've stood in front of a camera and
complained about it seriously if i get
running sprayed by the frenzy or the
stinger one more time
i'm gonna break my keyboard valerian
gamers rejoice no longer will you be one
pumped with a bucky from 15 meters away
like you're playing fortnite and this
time i'm here to ask the question
what if we just left the guns alone
what if we just let them suck
gretchen stop trying to make fetch
happen it's not going to happen
now to properly elaborate on my take
here let me take you back in time winter
of last year to be exact when believe it
or not running and gunning was
way better than it currently is in
ballard
it's so funny
[Music]
oh my god that's so funny
ryde had a half by gun with perhaps even
more ubiquity than last week's aries on
their hands and well you could basically
ferrari sprint around corners and clap
kids with it it cost 600 credits less
than the spectre and even if you had the
cash you'd buy the stinger
[Music]
so naturally riot nerfed the stinger and
now it sucks but it terrorized our rank
games for months everyone was calling it
the stinger meta and then a few months
later when spring sprung in 2021
we had
the bucky meta riot wanted to make
shotguns cool
[Music]
and well they turned this particular
shotgun into a sniper rifle
and then subsequently nerfed it into the
ground and lastly we have the meta right
before the release of neon where the
spectre ruled all half-buy options at
valor and champs for example the specter
was used 11.3 percent of the time
by far the most out of all non-full buy
non-pistol guns its closest competitor
the marshall sitting at a cool 1.7
and we all know much like the og stinger
you can still run and gun with this [ __ ]
i think going quick here towards this a
sight disproportionately
it's damn good
oh man
i'm dead
nice
what's up
long range with that spectre gonna be
able to get 146
hp left on celsius dapper can do that
zombies [ __ ]
now the reason for this little trip down
memory lane is to help bolster my
original point here
maybe it's just time we leave these guns
alone
let them suck the fact is in games like
valor and cs go players keep coming back
for that sweet sweet rifle feeling and
maybe the deagle that gets you there not
to spray an lmg
we'll leave that to the cod pros they
can have it and while honestly honestly
i commend riot games for trying to make
these guns uniquely playable
i would just like to avoid another aries
or bucky meta the way i see it these
guns are supposed to suck they're
supposed to be bad because the way the
game plays out they're just a stepping
stone to that sweet sweet phantom burst
and i'm not alone in that opinion just
ask
any counter-strike fan after years of
things like the cz functioning like an
ak the much-maligned krieg meta and the
tec-9 back in 2014 which is eerily
similar to the stinger meta cs go fans
began to just ask valve to leave the
guns alone glocks deagles the m4 the usp
the op
and the beloved ak that's it that's all
there's a part of me that truly believes
that if we left some of these
afterthought weapons as the worst
versions of themselves and started
tuning some of that precise gun play
that we thought we were getting with the
phantom and the vandal
our rank games might be a little bit
more fun now
with that said i acknowledge that this
is a rather
nuclear take and like i said in my last
video the fact that they've committed to
movement first agents like jet and neon
that make for a faster overwatch-like
experience is really appealing to new
players and players that are just trying
to have fun not sweat it's cool that you
can be raised and hold u-haul on find
with a judge and just
get him it is neat how well the odin
combos with sova's abilities it's
dynamic it adds depth to the game so
maybe
in this particular video more than any
i've ever done
i want to hear from you let me know in
the comments whether you think i'm a
crotchety old boomer who hates fun or
if they actually should just leave the
damn guns alone
one time i tried to play sky and ranked
and
you know you try to communicate with
your teammates and you're like you're on
breeze on a site and you're like i'm
flashing triple or i'm flashing double
doors and then you like okay let's go
and you're all like charging out of the
cave like you're in lord of the rings or
something and then you you get to
you get around the corner and you're
just like the only one there you get
shot behind your whole team still in the
cave
so yeah that's that's my rank experience
the key to rank
sentient teammates
this one sentient teammate